il a invité tous l'été Il nous donne des
sons l'année dernière il a passé les
vacances avec moi il a super attention
je suis désolé les mecs
fais attention
chez moi ici on paye rien ne t'inquiète
pas ok d'accord combien je vous dois 200
€
[Applaudissements]
. il est à la maison il est à la maison
il a la maison et je fais venir un
coiffeur et je lui dis bon on sort ce
soir
je lis bien à la maison et donc le
coiffeur il vient à la maison il me
coiffe et donc moi après je suis
fracasse je dis bon je vais dormir un
peu là derrière moi
t'inquiète pas c'est à moi le coiffeur
t'inquiète pas donc c'est bon donc lui
il fait coiffer et moi je suis en train
de dormir donc là
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il me dit
vas-y quoi sur moi j'aime pas quoi faire
à domicile il va me prendre une blinde
quoi on s'en sortir son matos une
tondeuse une tondeuse argent une
tondeuse oh je suis pas ça je fais ça au
salon là je vais donner 30 balles on en
parle plus 25 30 balles il commence à me
coiffer je suis content et tout et je
dis bon bah merci combien je te dois
100 euros
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
les t-shirts
aussi allez t-shirts rigolade je la mets
dans un magasin il voulait acheter ne
t'inquiète pas c'est la famille
pense que tu veux c'est chez moi ici bon
écoute-moi tu sais quoi je vais faire un
tour de voiture parce que j'ai pas dit
la voiture
j'étais mal garéiste ils m'ont écoute
moi je suis malgaré est-ce que tu veux
t'inquiète pas
revenir dans la voiture avec des sacs
ça c'est bien passé et là il me raconte
ma vie
il est bien super il vous irez bien la
vendeuse
je voulais essayer ben non j'essaye pas
j'ai pas le temps c'est bon on fait à la
confiance ici
alors je vous ai fait cinq pour cent
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il a pas voulu me dire au début
mais quoi tu fais la gueule non non il y
a des trucs sans essayer
[Rires]
au bout d'un moment il m'a balancé
l'histoire
il veut m'inviter au restaurant un
restaurant de grillades
et là aussi pareil
comment est ton frère il va où mon frère
il est là maintenant ah ouais bah tu
passes attends on va l'appeler FaceTime
voilà là
tu connais de Paris d'Istanbul de
Madagascar ils ont tout fait les 400
coups et c'est pour moi les mecs vas-y
envoie des grillades c'est pour moi il
sent bon ils vont à la voiture et je
reviens je vais payer combien je dois
j'ai toujours tout payé tellement cher
la détente et tout j'ai moi merci
beaucoup c'est c'était super franchement
on va revenir demain encore là tu veux
tiens tiens mon ami 327
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors ce qu'on va faire tu dis rien à
personne parce que j'ai pas d'argent je
reviens demain et je te paye demain je
reviendrai demain avec des gens et je
vais te dire le lendemain
je vais me promener je vais me promener
je vais faire un tour
c'est énorme c'est énorme l'histoire
avec lui moi ici attention
les fringues c'est incroyable les
fringues ils sont sous scellés je
n'aimais pas je les ai même pas encore
mis
il veut pas les mettre